[Musik]
nichts ist perfekt keine frage weder die
melanie auch ich nicht
ich habe mir ist jetzt sehr genau
überlegen sie sagten auch so offen ich
habe ja aus ihren reihen einige haben
mir geschrieben jetzt aber muss ein kopf
rollen und jetzt muss aber also einen
sie aber aus zusagen aus dem
publizistischen kreisen
und jetzt muss ein kopf rollen und so
weiter und das geht auch nicht ganz so
sicher
die melanie hat dann von sich aus nicht
angerufen wie das gesagt wir hatten in
den letzten sechs monaten deutlich
dunklere und schlimmeres stunden noch
gehabt und da war sie ein verlässlicher
eine verlässliche partnerin wie viele
andere in der zeit und ich jetzt auch
menschlich unangemessen gefunden wegen
einer zugegebenermaßen schlimmen panne
jetzt scheint ist 100 fälle zu gehen das
ist schlimm das wollen wir nicht
wegdiskutieren
eine ganze leistung über jahre hinweg
und auch in dieser zeit dermaßen auch zu
bewerten und ihre erfahrung jetzt wäre
jetzt immer neues damit zu vernehmen
während der abwägung schlechter wer
schlechter als die chance auch dass ein
stück weit jetzt wieder nicht nur
auszumerzen sondern halten neu
aufzustellen ich wollte auf diese
erfahren und auch auf die psychische
stärke die hatte melanie dann auch nicht
verzichten deswegen war die abweichung
wissen was ist falsch schon richtig
fehler am erkannt okay das wird versucht
ist alles abzustellen darf verhalten
optimistisch sein
ich glaube auch dass so was er nicht
mehr passieren kann wir waren auch dass
wenn die controlling strukturen
überprüfen müssen und wir werden
deswegen immer auch bei den tests
zentren die jetzt ein ende des monats
stattfinden sollen und anfang september
haben wir ganz bewusst ins heute abend
im innenminister abgesprochen mit der
melanie dass gerade diese choralen
testzentren in der federführung beim
innenministerium liegen warum das war
auch wenn es kalt so dass sozusagen das
innenministerium den hut auf hatte um
das ganze zu strukturieren ja also
fehler ist sicherlich dass man die idee
voran bringen
das mag sein das kann man auch noch
besser machen alles und aber trotzdem
bleibt es am ende eine sehr operative
panne und es auch keine panne der
ministerin selbst